it was a beautiful day in sardinia the
second largest italian island in the
mediterranean the sea was clear the air
was hot and the beaches were golden but
the cagliari diving club couldn't see
any of that they were roughly 250 meters
underneath the mediterranean sea
given the rich and extensive history of
the area they were sure to find some
interesting historical artifacts on the
ocean floor and they were indeed about
to find something incredible but this
history wasn't quite as dead as some old
roman pottery paolo bonacelli the most
experienced diver was the deepest of all
they decided to be a little more
ambitious this time than in previous
dives 20 miles off the sardinian coast
for paolo it was uncharted territory so
you could only imagine how amazed and
delighted he was when he saw the shape
of what seemed like a small town beneath
the water old stone buildings in a
classic roman or grecian style with
roofs made of thatched seaweed he
gestured to his fellow divers to follow
him they were amazed at how well
preserved the building seemed to be as
though they were still being lived in
and actively maintained to this day
despite being around 300 meters
underwater if they were able to take
some pictures and collect some artifacts
they'd be the talk of the local historic
community and probably be able to
finagle a payout from the whole
experience too that's when paolo spotted
something truly amazing a larger more
impressive structure like a miniature
palace surrounded by grangio statues of
humanoid figures in a circle around the
little palace each of the statues was an
imposing five meters tall with a faint
golden light emanating from each of them
while the statues were humanoid they
definitely weren't human their features
were strange and fish-like scales gills
tentacles paulo was in awe at the side
of them he took pictures and got closer
there was also a huge chasm in front of
the building perhaps some kind of
underwater thermal vent paulo was
curious he wanted to investigate further
he swam deeper and deeper what was at
the bottom of that chasm but lucky for
paulo he would never see what was at the
bottom of that chasm before he could
reach it something intercepted him from
the side something large and fast he
felt a white hot flash of pain his claws
raked across his chest tearing open the
rubber of his wetsuit paolo turned eyes
widening in horror to see a creature
staring at him like the statues it was
humanoid but not human an
anthropomorphic sea monster with
greenish skin its arms and legs coated
in thin scales its neck serrated into
fleshy gills he could see scraps of his
suits rubber hanging from its claws it
bore a mouthful of fangs and gave a
silent but threatening snarl paolo could
see something in the distance behind
this creature more figures like this one
emerging from the merc getting faster
getting closer paulo was a smart man but
it didn't take a genius to realize that
if he stuck around something terrible
was about to happen to him and the rest
of the cagliari diving club he turned
and fled paddling with all his might
away from the coming legion of aquatic
beasts the rest of the club saw the
experienced diver panicking and followed
his lead thanks to their quick thinking
and expertise they all managed to escape
with their lives and only a few minor
injuries but they had no idea of the
true extent of the mystery they were
leaving behind beneath the sea the
multiverse is a big place there are
alternate universes where the devour of
worlds escapes and destroys everything
we love and hold dear there are
alternate universes where the scp
foundation has gone haywire and
attempted to wipe out humanity through
controlled releases of all their
anomalies there are even universes where
a kill squad sent by the chaos
insurgency hunts down and assassinates
every member of the o5 council before
replacing them and leading the
foundation into a bold new era and there
are some universes where the scp
foundation is italian we've covered
scp-057 on this channel before in our
video on the most frightening rooms in
the scp universe but you've never seen
this
scp-057 because this is the italian
version scp-057-it
this localized anomaly off the coast of
sardinia is under the purview of the
italian division of the scp foundation
which works autonomously with its own
systems and terminology this scp is in a
frightening room that crushes its
trapped victims together this anomaly is
an entire city 300 meters beneath the
water of the mediterranean sea everyone
has heard of the mythical lost city of
atlantis a supposed underwater utopia
outlined by such great historical minds
as the ancient greek philosopher plato
it's something that people fantasize
about a beautiful idyllic society under
the sea divorced from all the petty
squabbles we deal with up on land but is
everything really better down where it's
wetter let's take a look and see when
paulo and the rest of the cagliari
diving club returned to the surface they
were happy to tell anyone that would
listen that they encountered aggressive
merman and an entire underwater city off
the coast of sardinia they even posted
their photos onto their official
facebook page along with photos of
paulo's gnarly chess scars that's when
the italian branch of the scp foundation
finally discovered them and decided to
intervene the foundation dispatched an
sir squad known as orerria notatia sirs
are the intelligence and research
section of the italian scp foundation a
kind of mobile task force that
investigates possible informational
leads paolo and his team were given
amnestic treatment and any evidence that
they'd collected was scrubbed from
existence meanwhile lieutenant marco
levini leader of the mobile task force
ssm2 squad aka leggio allantidis was
being dispatched to the source of the
problem scp-057-i-t
itself what started off as a relatively
straightforward exploratory mission soon
took an extremely strange turn lavini
and his men reported activity down in
the underwater city observing from the
safety of their armored foundation
submarine while the aquatic humanoids
living in
057-it were undeniably the same species
their culture seemed to be split up into
two unique groups one group had thinner
scales on their arms and legs this group
was more numerous having at least 60
active specimens and was characterized
by their extreme aggression towards any
outsiders as for the smaller group they
had thicker scales as well as a number
of eerily consistent injuries to their
hands feet and gills they were also
distinct from the thin scales in terms
of behavior as they were a far
friendlier more curious bunch at times
members of this subset would approach
the submarine and regard it with
detached fascination sometimes they
would even point at the submarine and
laugh though their reasons for doing
this are unknown eventually lieutenant
lavini was so confident in their safety
around the murr people that he and a few
other team members decided to disembark
from the submarine on a diving excursion
and properly explore the aquatic city
below this would prove to be a dangerous
tactical error on levine's part during
what seemed like a routine exploratory
mission lavini was ambushed by a
squadron of thin scales grabbed from
behind and kidnapped he was taken as a
hostage and spirited away into one of
the city's various buildings where a
thick scale known as letizia acted as
his warden but lavini soon found that
being under letizia's care was a
profoundly lucky turn of events on his
part both because it allowed him to
learn more about the situation and
because she was one of the small group
left in the city who hadn't become
dangerous fanatics that's right the mer
people were in the middle of a heated
civil war both from the observations of
lavini during his captivity and later
interviews conducted by project head dr
giuseppe pastillo with some liberated
members of the thick scales they learned
that a terrible religious conflict had
broken out in scp-057-it
the accounts coming from the rescued
citizens illustrated a similar backstory
to what the italian foundation had
theorized regarding the murr people they
were the descendants of people that
lived on the island of nisros up to the
14th century bce before it was
devastated by a volcanic eruption
forcing them into the ocean where they
evolved the ability to live in aquatic
environments through anomalous means
since this change this new species had
been operating in mediterranean waters
migrating regularly in order to avoid
detection passing their way of life from
generation to generation as the world
changed and shifted above them in many
ways they were quite similar to humans
such as their reproductive habits they
mate and reproduce after a gestation
period more like animals than fish
though their gestation period is
slightly shorter than human beings at
six months they largely speak latin
though the oldest merperson among them
also speaks ancient greek mer children
born in foundation containment have
shown strong language acquisition skills
as they have proven more than able to
learn modern italian and even more
fascinating from a standpoint of
sociological study the mer people have
formed their own unique culture under
the sea and this is where the problems
started abstaining from the belief of
the greek and roman pantheons their
ancestors looked up to the myrrh people
instead worshipped their own group of
water-bound deities whose images were
reflected in the great statues in the
center of the town the large building
near the statues and the chasm was the
home of the mayor the town's de facto
leader however what had been a workable
system for centuries began falling to
ruin when a strange religious fanaticism
began to spread a cult-like group soon
formed and began holding ceremonies
where they worshipped a powerful entity
in the chasm known as the great eye
this new cult was known as the cult of
the great eye of the mediterranean or
sea gem for short what began as a fringe
belief soon became a frenzy and took
over the better part of the town with
the acolytes of the great eye proving
themselves more than willing to spread
the gospel of their new deity with
violence some of the more arduino
non-believers were killed for their
heresy while others were simply
ritualistically mutilated in order to
prevent them from rebelling letizia had
her own evidence of these targeted
mutilations the thin scales had cut the
aquatic webbing from between her fingers
and toes making it harder for her to
swim away and escape other suspected
heretics were given the same treatment
the reason the thick scales even had
thicker scales was that they stole
forbidden technology from the mayor to
increase the strength of their scales
hoping it would help them better
withstand the torments of the acolytes
those involved in the stealing of this
technology were captured and summarily
executed for their acts of defiance in a
sense letizia was protecting lavini by
advising him against trying to escape
knowing the acolytes of the great eye
would kill him if he did she knew that
the only opportunity for escape would
come during the ceremony held by the
acolytes to honor their frightening
master when the day eventually came as
lavini was running low on everything
from food to oxygen everyone in the town
was forced out into the town center to
witness the ritual the acolytes gathered
around the chasm and began to chant in a
frightening unknown language as they
chanted a blinding light began to
emanate from the chasm and as blurry
shapes emerged nightmarish tentacled
gastropods soon began to take form truly
lovecraftian undersea monsters shortly
after the ritual the vinnie and the
thick scales were able to make a break
for it pursued by the acolytes of the
great eye it was a close one but
thankfully due to the intervention and
assistance of a trained mobile task
force the fanatical forces of the
acolytes were repelled and the fleeing
mer people along with lavini were
rescued a number of thick scales are now
willingly confined at site nituno an
italian foundation containment site
where they have undergone numerous
interviews with foundation staff
incidentally among them is the oldest
mer person previously present in
scp-057-i-t
the only one who spoke ancient greek
fluently he was different from the
others
extremely different in fact he was a
deity made into flesh one of the deities
replaced by the worshipers of the great
eye this unfortunate former god had done
everything to keep his people's lives
safe and peaceful but in spite of his
wisdom and best efforts hell had once
again broken loose not everything is all
well and good in scp-057-i.t
even if a human's body changes their
nature does not and the worst parts of
human nature seemingly followed these
unfortunate mer people into what should
have been their paradise under the sea
but all hope isn't lost if you were to
judge the entire human race on one
community in turmoil you probably
wouldn't leave with a very favorable
impression of us either correspondence
with a french branch of the scp
foundation reveals that myrrh creatures
aren't just localized to one warring
underwater city in sardinia mermaids
have also been discovered and confirmed
by foundation field agents off the coast
of france eighty percent of the ocean
still remains unmapped to this day who
knows what else is out there just
waiting to be found now go check out the
horror of body stealing rain
scp-3300 and scp-1861
the crew of the hms wintershimer for
more water-based horrors from the scp
foundation